ach du
scheiße alle die auch immer schreiben
spitz AX ist besser
als Schwert ja AX hat so ein langen
recharge oder wie das
heißt deswegen fine ich Schwert irgendwi
deutlich besser es kommt wieder wir
müssen uns hochbauen ja ich weiß das
werde ich jetzt auch machenumut euch
jetzt hoch weil jetzt wieder dieses
blöde Gegner Ding kommt so Sandy du
baust jetzt den Block ab dann läufst du
ganz schnell weg okay ich bin
[Musik]
oben du hast gesagt wir sollen uns
abhauen diger du sollst nicht bis zum
Mond bauen du kannst von da gar nicht
jetzt Tier erreichen ich dachte so drei
Blöcke hoch Bau D wieder runter okay so
kannst du jetzt mal den unteren Block da
unten abbauen welchen warte ich glaub
ich kann es auch selber machen
dein perfekt hat super geklappt jetzt
kommt wieder ein Creeper
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
chill tja wer denkt jetzt wer ihr
seid bye
bye bye
bye Ciao
kako
h lass uns mal kurz pennen gehen bist du
im Boot komm mit steig ein ich bring
dich zu dein Bett
okay warum machst du
das B so dick wir kommen nicht durch
scheiße ich töte mal ein paar von
unseren Freunden
hier Leute icht wirklich nur
ab warum macht man sowas wir brauchen
die letzten 100 Blöcke wir sind bei
Block
2491 von
2599 100 Blöcke noch das heißt wir
werden heute tatsächlich one block
beenden e Sander mach mal auch
Linksklick auf den enderkristall hier
drauf den ich gerade platziert habe dann
kriegst du so schnelle abbaukräfte und
so ein KS guck mal das Ding was hier so
schön
leuchtet
du hast D selbst in die Luft gesprengt
guck in chat selfie sandra wurde von
selfie Sandra in die Luft gesprengen
kann selbst schenken du
kleinerur noch nur noch 16 Blöcke
countch3 blöe noch s Blöcke noch noch F
noch vi noch D noch Z noch ein
und jetzt
ist der letzte Block wir haben 12
enderaugen ein endstein und 12
enderportalo was okay
tschüss das hier stört mich ein bisschen
will so normaler
blockmt hast du
Eisen warum haben wir kein
Eisen
nichts passiert hier gerade bei mir bei
mir ist alles super Sand da danke alles
gut danke der Nachfrage hier ist nichts
passiert okay s bist du bereit ja
Laser ich sehe gar nichts das ist nicht
wahr wir sind so weit vom Arsch
weg
ich RAS komplett aus es ist schwieriger
als gedacht bin ich ganz ehrlich wo bist
du ich bin direkt beim Enderdrachen und
was machst du ich versuch natürlich
abzuschießen nee den noch nicht
abschießen
ja wie machst du das ich Ziel auf die
Dinger oben kann ich das mit meinem auch
machen ich genau das gleiche du bist
sogar eigentlich besser ausgerüstet als
ich gerade der enderdrache ist gerade
relativ
[Musik]
nah an
mir er ist gerade über mir oh mein
Gotter er ist beim letzten
Ding ich glaube jetzt ist alles zerstört
jetzt geht's los jetzt müsste er sich
eigentlich hier unten
hinbewegen zum Portal Sandy jetzt müssen
wir nur noch
schlagen
diger komm wieder rein Sandy aber ich
habe kein kein
Kopf brauchst du nicht ich lass deine
Items hier bin da ja ja lass sie e das
ist einfach das Ende von one
block sehr
gut
wir haben
gleich noch ein
Schlag Bo wie kriegen hin das ist
einfach das Ende von one
[Musik]
block oh mein
Gott
Laser oh mein Gott wir haben es
geschafft wir haben es
geschaffter wir haben Minecraft one
block durchgespielt Freunde ich bin
schon e sehr sehr sehr sehr stolz auf
uns wir sind halt nicht die besten
Minecraft Spieler deswegen ist es für
uns schon Errungenschaft let ja Sandra
was hat dir gefallen am
Projekt ich habe viel mehr gebaut als
sonstmer abgebaut als sonst und was hat
dir nicht
gefallen man war weniger kreativ also
was mir gefallen hat war dass immer so
ein bisschen Abwechslung drin war durch
die ganzen Blöcke die halt kamen und es
kam mal die Monster mal die freundlichen
Dinger dann dieser schalkerkisten es hat
schon echt für einige sehr sehr lustige
Momente gesorgt obwohl man nur in so
einer ganz ganz minimal kleinen Welt war
und was ich nicht so gut fand war dass
ich es mit dir gemacht habe also Spaß
also Spaß das allerbeste war ich war am
Ende die enen Ding gemacht er Drachen ja
ich war kurz vorm Sterben und dann
dachte ich mir so boah gehe ich jetzt
auch noch mal dahin und schlag aber dann
dachte ich mir so die könnte schaffen
und dann hast du ja mit dem letzten
Schlag noch hingekriegt ja m ich will
die mit den nen Bizeps EU leute danke
schön für den ganzen Support danke schön
dass ihr mit dabei wart bei diesen
Minecraft one block Projekt Sandra und
ich werden uns jetzt in den Streams
anderen Spielen widmen klar immer noch
mal ab und zu Minecraft aber vielleicht
dann eher so andere Welt oder so ein
bisschen auf lauki lachkick hah hii und
nicht auf Projektbasis angelehnt sondern
eher erstmal auf andere Spiele gehen und
ja ich freue mich auf andere Spiele ja
Sandra wird jetzt abgeholt von daher
ja wir sehen uns die Woche auf jeden
Fall noch wieder ne ja im Stream ja wir
gehen tatsächlich die Tage wieder live
aber das kündigen wir dann auch ein
bisschen an am besten wie gesagt einfach
folgen folgt uns hier auf Twitch also
Sandra folgen und mir folgen ich wünsche
euch noch einen schönen Tag Ciao Leute
Ciao Leute haut rein Ciao Sandra
[Musik]